look you are somebody who
you j the way that you connect with your
fans through social media is so real is
so um
relatable there have been a couple times
as of late where people are coming for
you for a tick tock or they're coming
for you a picture
how do you balance
staying relatable and connected to your
fans with knowing that there might be
those responses does it make you think
twice when you post how do you come to
what you're gonna do
the only time i think twice now
is when i do a tick tock
honestly
after that you know why after that one
because
i thought i was being cool and
apparently i wasn't being cool so
i was like okay i got this one wrong i
was trying to be cool like my daughter
and copy what she was doing but make it
my own but it didn't work
so now i guess i second-guess tic-tock
because
it is clearly for the younger people
i can't even tell you and i'm just
i'm just trying to
stay hip and do my thing you know
but
but in you know for real to answer that
question i
nothing i do on my social media except
for promotional pieces when i have a
movie or the clothing line or skin care
i mean those yes are planned but i
really don't plan any of the other
things i i put on there and i'm just
trying to be real and authentic and when
when you do get you know and we've all
felt it um when you get those people who
have heavy criticisms for things you do
i don't know if you're like this but
look it's like one one mean comment can
hit me so much harder than like i let
myself feel 100 nice ones you're always
so positive and happy
what do you have to say to those people
or how do you react when you get that
criticism that hate
well
i you know sometimes you try to look at
where it's coming from and
sometimes when they have like zero
followers you know that that's they're
just it's like a troll you know and
they're just
but but sometimes you know it hurts when
people
you know they come to a conclusion and
i'm like oh well i i kind of feel like
well maybe you haven't followed me for a
while or you don't see the consistency
of my life over the years because i
think that speaks volumes you just have
to scroll past it and get over it
sometimes you vent to your friends and
then you're like okay let's move on yeah
yeah we we tend to judge each other on
one moment instead of all the moments
yeah
all right so candace you're coming to me
from a wine cellar where are you i want
to be there
i know it's pretty great it is our wine
cellar in napa valley
you know what this is perfect because i
feel like the best way to enjoy your
incredible movies playing aurora is with
a nice glass of wine
i think you're right
it's like the perfect way to enjoy it
just decide you know try to figure out
who committed the crime
uh just leisurely watch this movie try
to get the
the right suspects in order just don't
drink too much wine or you really won't
solve the mystery
this is true you will totally lose it
because there's actually a lot of
suspects in this movie
have fun on your honeymoon row
only you could stumble on a body on your
honeymoon are they talking about who
might have killed him
this is police business road not yours
since when has that ever stopped me yeah
my aurora tea garden honeymoon honey
murder
a warranty garden is the only person i
know that would find a dead body while
she's on this romantic
um like row boat experience with her
husband
on the lake
and then their body appears but um
i was gonna ask candace how many more
murders can this woman just find herself
in the middle of at some point will we
will she have to start questioning it
hopefully not because i want to make a
whole lot more movies
this is number 17 right how long will
you stick with aurora
i i honestly i hope a long time i love
this character i feel like her her she
just got started on a new season of life
because she got married in the last
movie
we've been with her through 16 other
movies before we've gotten to this point
so now there it's like a whole new world
for her in solving these mysteries with
her husband slash partner in crime the
movies are always so good to watch
they're such a great escape what do you
love about playing her
oh i love aurora because she's fearless
and she's never afraid to get her hands
dirty and
just get in there to solve the mystery
she has a lot of courage and she kicks
butt so i love playing her and i just
love these movies because of what you
said they're they're family friendly
movies you can watch this with your
eight-year-old you know it's um it's all
about figuring out who's done it and
there's nothing ever scary in it or gory
they're just really fun mysteries to
solve what three things would you
generally say you've learned about crime
song
well don't touch anything because you
don't want your fingerprints on it
you don't want to contaminate the
evidence
so don't touch anything
and then you have to think
like the person who committed the crime
you have to get into their brain so it
might not be the most logical thing
to do
you kind of have to think of logically
um and number three
uh
don't don't
don't talk to other people about it
like your best friend who's a
blabbermouth because then she might
give away the secrets and talk about the
person who the suspect who actually is
the killer and then you might get in
trouble yourself
honestly incredibly solid tips not just
for crime solving but life i think you
know
don't mess with other people's stuff try
to put yourself in other people's shoes
and don't gossip it's just great and
aurora is uh this time as you said she
finds a body while on her pre honeymoon
her honeymoon pre-honey yes um do did it
take you back at all to your own
honeymoon what do you remember about it
[Laughter]
the only thing that was similar is that
both of our honeymoons involved water
i
my husband and i went to hawaii for our
honeymoon
we were only there for two nights
because
after the first day my husband realized
that he would not go in the ocean
because of sharks
so we called the travel agent and went
home
are you serious
did he not think beforehand like i know
there's gonna be an ocean there and i'm
okay with getting in it or not
i know i i i don't know
i really at this point 25 years later i
don't even know um by the way of course
a happy birthday to your lovely daughter
23. thank you can you believe you have a
23 year old i can't believe you have a
23 year old
no
some days it's like i can't believe i
have adult children all three of my
children are adults
and time does go by very very fast
but i love i love that they are young
adults it's so much fun to see where
they're going what they're doing
and i love cheering them on because i'm
i'm a good cheerleader it's what i love
to do and so
um but yeah it goes by so fast i feel
like this happens every time she has a
birthday but i i you know i'm doing my
research for this interview and there's
about 20 headlines about how you two are
twins and you look exactly the same and
you're twinning
do you see it as much as everyone else
does
no i don't and i don't think everyone
sees it that way i don't
i i love the headline that we look like
sisters that makes
my mom feel young that's very nice but
natasha actually looks a lot more like
my husband and his side of the family
yes we both have blonde hair and blue
eyes but facially
my boys look more like i do and natasha
looks more like her dad okay well we'll
wait for those headlines
so many movies ahead do you have any
ideas for where you'd like to see her go
next any types of mysteries to solve or
places to be do you ever pitch these in
the writer's room
oh yes we do because we're creating all
these stories from
since
movie 11 wow because it was based on a
book series right and you exhibited
produced yeah i executive produce all of
them so we are always throwing around
story ideas for the next
movies and we do already have the
outlines for the next few and they're
pretty fun and i can tease that
in the next one we're gonna have some
flashback
scenes of aurora and her best friend
sally in their younger days
candace and there might be somebody
playing me
young
like teenage ish that you might know
somebody who kind of looks like me so
he's your twin
yeah maybe oh
okay well i think she'd be the perfect
person for the part
we're just gonna slap a red wig on her i
wanted to ask you the last time i talked
to you was when i believe you were
heading into or already into quarantine
with mary lou henner to film
so how did that all turn out when you
guys were like hunkered down together
and had to quarantine as long as you did
oh it's been great it really
she's been my saving grace in quarantine
and i and i think the same for her
because we have each other because it
gets a little it gets a little like
crazy lonely when you can't
go outside for 14 days you're just stuck
in your little space and so
that was really fun and i won't have
mary lou this time when i go when i go
up there but um
but i'm gonna make it through doesn't
she famously have like a photographic
memory
yes but different than photographic but
her memory capacity is
much larger than most people and she's
one of maybe like 12 people in the world
so she can remember every day of her
life
and every detail what she was wearing
she'll know a date what day of the week
a certain day fell on on whatever year
she was alive what is it like to be
friends with someone who can remember
all that
it's great because she she always
prompts with lots of questions
and
um and then she gets you remembering
things so i actually love it and she's
like the best we call her a swizzle
stick or that's what she calls her she's
a swizzle stick so it's like when you're
at a party and you're sitting at a table
with a bunch of people that you don't
know mary lou just knows how to ask all
the questions and kind of stir
everything up and she just keeps it all
going she's like the best swizzle to
stick and then that memory is like her
party trick i love it she's the vibe
lady great yeah she is now you do so
much incredible work tell me about
september
so skip skip1.org is a nonprofit
organization that i've been a part of
for
10 years plus i'm on the board of it it
was founded by one of my best friends
chalene bryan
and
we build kitchens in orphanages and
schools all over the world where they
don't have a kitchen and often
this meal
that the children get there at the
school
is the only meal they'll have that day
and so um and we also do a lot of work
with the homeless community here in the
u.s so every year i promote skip one and
skip september and we're hoping that
everyone will just you know every dollar
counts every single dollar and it means
a lot to us and it means a lot to those
kids